from the east coast of the vale the
fingers
reach out into the narrow sea four rocky
peninsulas plagued by wind and rain
and barren to all but the hardiest of
weeds
the ancestral home of house baelish
our house began with my great
grandfather a bravosi cell sword who
came to the veil at the invitation of
house corbre
my grandfather raised himself to the
status of hedge knight
and even managed to acquire a bit of
land and to keep on the smallest of the
fingers
though i do believe he often missed
sleeping under his titular hedges
the only thing worse than owning a
dreary and desolate land
is owning only a small portion of it
luckily
i didn't spend much time there as a
child
during the war of the nine penny kings a
cheap name for a cheap cause
where other men fought for the king my
father fought to befriend hoster tully
lord paramount of the trident and head
of one of the oldest and greatest houses
in westeros
thanks to my father's heroic efforts
lord hoster agreed to foster me at
riverrun with his own children
until then my whole world had been a
small tower on the gulf-stained rocks of
the fingers
but when i first saw the stone walls of
riverrun rising from the trident
towering over me back then i was a
little more easily impressed
the boy in me thought the gods
themselves must live in such a place
i soon learned otherwise lord tully's
son
edmure was quick to ensure i would never
forget myself in their house
he nicknamed me littlefinger after my
size and homeland
and the name was just cruel enough to
stick
his sisters lice and catelyn made me a
pawn in their kissing game
traded back and forth between them for
practice
needless to say i enjoyed spending time
with them more than edmure
and as we grew older the game began to
change
as all games do liza grew more bold
and cat more demure when lord tully
announced cat's betrothal to a brood
from the north whom she'd never met
i realized her duty would outweigh any
feelings she had for me
fool that i was i challenged this
brandon stark to a jewel
for her hand he was a warrior i was a
boy
if cat had not intervened he would have
killed me
and laughed over my corpse before my
insolence
lord tully banished me from riverrun no
matter
i had learned everything i needed by
then i would fight my battles not with
swords
but with wits a few men could match me
even then house baelish might have died
out on the rocks of the fingers
i was again a poor lord with no allies
and no prospects except
if i were lucky the daughter of a
middling merchant
then opportunity arose the mad king
executed that brandon stark and incited
a rebellion
my old friend lysa tully was married
after john aaron
lord of the vale to cement the alliance
against the iron throne bringing her
within my circle again
i quickly capitalized on our former
affection
and persuaded her to have me appointed
as controller of customs at gull town
the vale's greatest port
wars burn gold like wildfire when i
increased the port's income tenfold
her husband took notice of this lowly
lord from the fingers
and when the new and profligate king
robert needed a master of coin who could
find gold where no one else could
why lord aaron knew just the man
once house baelish had no lands no name
and no gold now we have quite a lot of
each
what new rung will the next generation
climb
let us not be hasty i'm not finished yet